[Music]
hey sam and sean this is colby from
woodbridge virginia it seems like you
guys are always finding cool stuff
whether that's media or cool tools so
anyway my question is what have you been
into recently thanks
okay so the question of the the one
question friday we got was basically
around
what are just random we seem to be into
really random things what are some of
these random things that we're really
into right now stuff that we really like
it could be a podcast it could be um a
video it could be a book it could be an
app or a tool anything like that what
are we into it's kind of like our info
diet or the tools in our tool belt that
we really like right now so sam what do
you got all right
i'll write off all three of mine because
they're all related so the first one
the both of these might sound all three
might sound a little obvious but hear me
out so youtube premium are you a
subscriber to youtube premium i am a
long time youtube premium subscriber
most people aren't and so i actually
unsubscribed from spotify so i don't use
paid spotify anymore i only use youtube
and the reason being is hey i watch all
my tv on there but b
you can listen to any music and they
make playlists for you and then you can
lock your phone and put it in your
pocket and you can listen to music
playlists and it's way better than
spotify because they have live versions
and like unreleased versions and like
illegal stuff you know like things that
were like you know aren't copyrighted
things like that so i like youtube
premium the second one do you ever
listen to audible i am not an audiobook
guy i always found it boring and a
little slow i kind of tuned it out
so there's this thing called audible
original so first of all there's audible
plus which is if you pay for it you get
all these free audio books so i'm always
clicking around but they've got some
that are as short as 30 minutes so like
short stories or like a short like class
but then they have audible originals and
they'll do like courses remember youtube
or itunes university it's almost like
that so they like put like whole like
stanford lectures so i just click on one
of the lectures and listen for a few
minutes on audible originals or they do
this other thing where they have these
like huge productions where it's an
audio book but there's like famous
actors and multiple of them so it's
almost like a play or a movie but
audible only and it's free if you're a
subscriber so i like that and the last
thing all related have you ever used the
app libby have you heard of libby never
heard of this
do you have a library card
no
okay so if you go to your local library
and you get a card which is free you can
enter in your library card to this app
called libby and you can access
unlimited amounts of ebooks and audio
books so long as the library in your
town has it
only only from one library no no no no
from like it's like everything like in
like anything you could imagine it's
likely there
yeah but listen there's one major
downside which is some things like the
popular titles they'll like or they're
only allocated i don't know how they do
this they're only allocated a certain
amount like 10 copies so like there's
this book called catch me if you can
that i wanted to read it was pretty
popular so i had to click request hold
and then like i got it like three days
later so you just request like you want
like 10 20 30 50 things and like you
know each thing is released like every
couple of days and so it's not always
instantaneous but a lot of times it is
but it's it's called libby free
audiobooks and free ebooks it's pretty
sick that's kind of amazing i had never
heard of that and i feel like nobody
knows about that so they're not gonna be
checked out um
when i when i go do it or at least where
i'm from uh okay so i'm gonna give you a
few things that i'm really into right
now i'm just gonna go quick because none
of these are super revolutionary but
they're just things i like
so
sending voice notes and imessage i have
i went from i never sent a voice note
and i was like
why is this feature even here and i
heard that people in china and asia love
to do it because it's slow to type there
i think because now i'm a dad i'm always
just like on the go or not by my
computer all the time i can't i'm
holding a kid in one arm and i'm just
trying to type in the other i have gone
all in on on voice notes it's basically
how i run my business now as i'm just
sending voice notes all day to my team
this data is wrong every freaking time
have you heard of hubspot
hubspot is a crm platform where
everything is fully integrated well i
can see the clients hold history calls
support tickets emails and
here's a task from three days ago i
totally missed
hubspot grow better
dude i hate voice notes
i hate them well you hate receiving them
you hate me i see receiving them so if
we're if you and i are in friend mode
i'm not listening to one if you and i
are in work mode well no not even you or
me if me and an employee are in work
mode i expect they're going to listen to
mine if i'm the boss and so i get why
that's cool but if we're peers and you
send me one i just automatically default
to uh
yeah
that's the response it's definitely an
fu to the receiver it's like you know
sit here and listen to me talk slowly
and ramble for a minute but like hey
that's kind of what this podcast is too
so you know whatever all right my second
one um this app that's called i think
it's called compounding i think you use
this too compound or compounding you
have this app
the personal finance one
yeah it's basically just one app that
lets you plug in basic metrics like uh
if you started with 100 grand and it's
compounding at a six percent rate in 10
years it'll be here 15 years it'll be
here 25 years i'll be here and the
reason i do this is not because every
day i need to run a compounding interest
calculation
but every day i should just as a
reminder of the power of simple
compounding i think warren buffett has
said you know compounding
interest is the eighth wonder of the
world or something like that 100 true
and i think it is very like compounding
interest basically breaks your brain
it's very hard to like foresee how a a
simple change between five percent or
eight percent will matter over a 10 year
or 15 year period but it matters in a
big way yeah it's really fun
because i just have a compound interest
one yeah this is this is that's all it
does okay but it's simple and it's my
reminder that slow and steady wins the
race because i'm pretty add when it
comes to like investments ideas things
like that so i need to remind myself of
the power of compound interest over a
long term okay related there's a twitter
account that you should follow that
everybody i think should follow called i
never give twitter accounts this kind of
shine because
we do got that influence it's gonna blow
them up but this person deserves it
their name is 10k diver have you ever
seen this account i love them
10k diver
is based is just basic uh personal
finance so it's just basic or not
personal finance basic financial
knowledge so it'll be like
hey if you're ever looking at a company
have a cup of coffee and sit down
because this sunday we're talking about
balance sheets how to look at them what
to learn in a bubble and he just breaks
it down so simply
so beautifully
ver every like simple finance finance
concept is being broken down by this
person they've shot up they have like
250 000 followers now
and uh after this they'll have at least
252 000 followers i believe and so that
this account is to me one of my favorite
high signal things i normally hate
twitter threads i love this guy's
twitter threads i find a lot of benefit
in just re reviewing the basics or
learning the basics for the first time
of something that i didn't really
understand or know so 10k diver's my
next one there's a billion websites on
chrome but most people are using it
ineffectively here's the five best
plugins that you need to be using right
now shout out to that guy jack did you
see he did a mock thread on these he
goes
there are 26 letters in the alphabet but
most people don't know how to use them
here's my favorite letters and how to
use them
a
a is an awesome letter he did this he
got like a hundred thousand i sent it to
him right when he did it i go this is
amazing that thread did over a hundred
thousand hundred thousand likes maybe
two hundred thousand that's hilarious
um all right second thing
the next one is um
i talked about this before the trigger
point massage ball
so
when we were at camp mfm my i had like
an achilles problem you were like hey
you need to use this there gun to loosen
it up and uh this other guy was like yo
use this he threw me like a lacrosse
ball yeah and he's like use this to roll
out your calf and i did and uh it like i
went from i wasn't gonna be able to play
to like i was able to play you know like
just because that thing loosened it up
so well
and um i forgot to give back to the guys
so i ended up bringing this lacrosse
ball home and two things happen
one start playing lacrosse love
no i love just having a ball in my hand
at old all times like just when i was
walking through the airport i was just
bouncing it around
dude just i'm like a little child having
a ball just makes my life 15 better i
love fiddling
with like you know a lacrosse ball it's
amazing and so i had it through the
airport the airplane i have it at home
all the time now i'm playing with this
thing and i'm also using it for these
trigger point massages for this like uh
you know uh fascia release or whatever
they call it this is this thing that
helps you feel more limber and loose
um
okay i have another fitness related one
that sounds gross
but for somebody out there this might be
helpful
goat milk you ever drink goat milk
not much i i eat a lot of that goat
cheese but no goat milk kind of has
grossed me out oh well goat cheese is
the creme de la creme we all know that
milk most people are a little bit
grossed out about or they just don't
know about it i got put onto this by my
trainer he's like hey if you want to put
something in your your smoothies or
shakes protein shakes or whatever
instead of using normal milk used goat
milk for most adults you're able to
digest goat milk better
and i think also like the enzymes and
goat milk don't um
like block the protein enzymes so if
you're drinking a protein shake and you
drink normal like like lactose based
milk uh i think there's like some
inhibition where it doesn't like work as
well but tastes better but doesn't work
as well so goat milk has been a little
trick and my last fitness one
walking backwards
which is from the the knees over toes
guy playbook
uh i have had knee problems at both
knees i've torn my mcl on both sides
i've dislocated both kneecaps before
i do not have good knees in general and
i'm trying to work on that and one of
the things that's helped me
feel better and like you know run better
all the stuff is
doing you know what they call it like
regression movements basically going in
the opposite way that you normally go so
let's say you always sit hunched over at
a computer then you need to do specific
exercise going in the opposite direction
to sort of like you know counterbalance
this other movement you've been
habituated to most of us only run and
walk forward so back pedaling is an
amazing way to sort of like strengthen
and
push blood flow into the parts of your
body that need it and i feel better
doing like this like five-minute
backwards walk every single day so uh
looks goofy as hell walking around the
neighborhood backwards but it's a thing
that i'm doing that i enjoy right now
chad perry you're talking about lacrosse
balls and
walking backwards
yeah god damn okay
chattington
[Laughter]
first name sean middle named tucker i'm
here
[Laughter]
all right well that's one one question
friday
[Music]
you